Star Wars: The Last Jedi featured a Skywalker
leaving his lightsaber behind - but will Star
Wars: Episode IX see another member of the
legendary family pick it up during a pivotal
scene?
According to leaked information regarding
the forthcoming installment in the space-faring
saga, it's apparently a guarantee.
Express recently obtained a description of
a "tantalizing" Episode IX scene that features
Carrie Fisher's General Leia wielding a "classic
Jedi lightsaber" - the Skywalker saber.
Not only is Leia said to hold it in the film,
but the headstrong Rebel Alliance leader will
reportedly also ignite it.
The leak claims that, during an important
sequence in Episode IX, Leia is on a world
"that appears to be a mix between Endor, Tatooine,
and Jakku - so basically, the middle of nowhere.
"Where are you from?
Nowhere.
No one's from nowhere.
Jakku.
Alright, that is pretty much nowhere."
Speculation is that this could be the planet
of Batuu, located in the Outer Rim.
Wearing a black outfit that looks "almost
like a robe," Leia is seen standing next to
Maz Kanata, C-3PO, and R2-D2, "holding the
Skywalker lightsaber and examining it."
The scene description reads, quote:
"She begins to hold it in a Jedi-like stance
and activates it, pointing it towards a city
that looks like it has gone through battle."
Though anyone, Force-sensitive or not, can
ignite a lightsaber, it's interesting to imagine
Leia activating one given her ties to the
Force.
Film fans were first made aware of Leia's
Force sensitivity over 30 years ago, in The
Empire Strikes Back, during the scene in which
her twin brother Luke implemented the Force
to reach out to her - thus granting Leia the
opportunity to save Luke from falling to his
death on Cloud City.
Her Force responsiveness was again explored
- this time in a much bigger way - in 2017's
The Last Jedi.
During an intense battle with the First Order,
Leia and a number of her fellow Rebels were
flung into deep space after an explosion destroyed
part of Leia's ship.
It looked as though Leia was done for.
But just as viewers began preparing to say
goodbye to Leia, the General channeled the
Force and used its power to pull herself back
onto the ship.
However, just because Leia will purportedly
get a lightsaber in Episode IX doesn't mean
that she's channeling the Force - and it also
doesn't mean that she has risen to replace
her brother Luke as the surviving Jedi of
the Skywalker family.
The leak concludes with an explicit statement
alleging the exact opposite:
"This does not indicate that Leia is a Jedi.
The stance is done more in a victorious way.
It could be the site of a First Order defeat."
Overall, Episode IX including a scene in which
Leia activates a lightsaber seems entirely
feasible - and it wouldn't be difficult for
Abrams and the horde of hyper-talented special
effects artists on board the project to create
a Leia-led sequence several years after Fisher's
death.
The Episode IX creative team will make use
of rotoscoping techniques to take previously
captured footage of Fisher as Leia in The
Force Awakens and The Last Jedi and place
it over newly shot material, creating brand-new
scenes for Episode IX without resorting to
making a CGI version of Leia.
We all know how that looks.
But, at the end of the day, this is an unsubstantiated
leak.
As with every rumor, fan-made theory, and
wild piece of speculations, you should take
these details with a grain of salt.
Sure, the information sounds awesome, but
none of it has been confirmed.
Lucasfilm and the entire Episode IX cast and
crew are keeping an air-tight lid on details,
so we can't imagine that anyone involved with
the upcoming pic will be rushing to comment
on this new leak anytime soon.
Everyone will just have to wait until Star
Wars: Episode IX opens in December 2019 to
find out if Leia truly does light up a saber.